ce restaurant est l'un des rares à avoir
ouvert ses portes à kharkiv
ici bruit ambiant et musique permettent
d'oublier les sirènes et les bombes
russe commet quelques minutes
ce bar est le seul endroit où on peut se
reposer
venir discuter et voir des gens
ça devient beaucoup plus facile
maintenant il ya moins de bombardements
les gens commencent à revenir
et ça c'est magnifique
à l'extérieur le retour à la réalité et
rapide par tous les bâtiments du centre
historique sont en ruine
1600 immeubles d'habitations ont été
détruits selon la mairie beaucoup ont
tout perdu et viennent chercher un peu
de nourriture distribuées par le
gouvernement
on est ici parce qu'on n'a pas d'argent
pas de travail j'ai travaillé dans un
café et avec la guerre les choses
terribles nous est arrivé ils vont
dépasser au dessus de nous
le centre ville n'a pas été bombardée
depuis le début de la semaine mais le
bruit des explosions à seulement
quelques kilomètres
bien encore plus et en cadeau bien
précaire
des milliers de personnes sont toujours
réfugiées dans le métro
chacun essaie de survivre dans cette
abbaye construit au temps de l'urss
et astier sépare les familles s'abritent
ici là c'est pour un jeune couple ici
c'est moi et mon mari est là bas c'est
une vieille dame
il fait froid et humide j'espère que ce
sera bientôt fini
c'est difficile de garder ce wagon
propre et de prendre une douche mais on
fait de notre mieux
impossible pour eux de savoir quand ils
rentreront chez eux mais les autorités
encouragent encore des habitants un
rester dans les abris
il serait extrêmement difficile pour les
civils de revenir à une vie normale
kharkiv est défigurée vous voyez encore
derrière moi les stigmates des tirs de
missiles cette université détruite mais
certains pensent déjà à l'avenir comme
le conseil municipal qui a décidé de
renommer certaines rues ici la bulle
moscou va se transformer en avenue des
héros de kharkiv